[Music]
two
perfectly rational gingerbread men
crispy
and chewy are out strolling when they're
caught by a fox
seeing how happy they are he decides
that instead of simply
eating them he'll put their friendship
to the test with a cruel dilemma
he'll ask each gingerbread man whether
he'd
opt to spare or sacrifice the other
they can discuss but neither will know
what the other chose
until their decisions are locked in if
both choose to spare the other the fox
will eat just
one of each of their limbs if one
chooses to spare while the other
sacrifices
the sparer will be fully eaten while the
traitor will run away with all his limbs
intact finally if both choose to
sacrifice
the fox will eat three limbs from each
in game theory this scenario is called
the prisoner's dilemma to figure out how
these
gingerbread men will act in their
perfect rationality
we can map the outcomes of each decision
the rows represent crispy's choices and
the columns
are chewies meanwhile the numbers in
each cell
represent the outcomes of their
decisions as measured in the number of
limbs each would keep so do we expect
their friendship
to last the game first let's consider
chewie's options
if crispy spares him chewy can run away
scot-free by sacrificing crispy
but if crispy sacrifices him chewy can
keep one of his limbs
if he also sacrifices crispy no matter
what crispy decides
chewy always experiences the best
outcome
by choosing to sacrifice his companion
the same is true for crispy
this is the standard conclusion of the
prisoner's dilemma
the two characters will betray one
another their strategy to
unconditionally sacrifice their
companion is what
game theorists call the nash equilibrium
meaning that neither can gain by
deviating from it
crispy and chewy act accordingly and the
smug
fox runs off with a belly full of
gingerbread
leaving the two former friends with just
one leg to stand on
normally this is where the story would
end but a wizard happened to be watching
the whole mess
unfold he tells crispy and chewy that as
punishment for betraying each other they
are doomed to repeat this dilemma for
the rest of their lives
starting with all four limbs at each
sunrise
now what happens this is called an
infinite prisoner's dilemma and it's a
literal
game changer that's because the
gingerbread men
can now use their future decisions as
bargaining chips for the present ones
consider this strategy
both agree to spare each other every day
if one ever chooses to sacrifice the
other will retaliate by choosing
sacrifice for the rest of eternity
so is that enough to get these poor
sentient baked goods
to agree to cooperate to figure that out
we have to factor in another
consideration
the gingerbread men probably care about
the future
less than they care about the present in
other words
they might discount how much they care
about their future limbs
by some number which we'll call delta
this is similar to the idea of inflation
eroding the value of money
if delta is one half on day one they
care about
day two limbs half as much as day one
limbs
day three limbs one quarter as much as
day one limbs
and so on a delta of zero means
that they don't care about their future
limbs at all so they'll repeat their
initial choice of mutual sacrifice
endlessly but as delta approaches one
they'll do anything possible to avoid
the pain
of infinite triple limb consumption
which means they'll choose to spare each
other
at some point in between they could go
either way
we can find out where that point is by
writing the infinite series
that represents each strategy setting
them equal to each other
and solving for delta that yields
one-third meaning that as long as crispy
and chewy care about tomorrow
at least one-third as much as today
it's optimal for them to spare and
cooperate
forever this analysis isn't unique to
cookies and wizards
we see it play out in real life
situations like trade negotiations
and international politics rational
leaders must
assume that the decisions they make
today will
impact those of their adversaries
tomorrow
selfishness may win out in the short
term but with the proper
incentives peaceful cooperation is not
only possible
but demonstrably and mathematically
ideal
as for the gingerbread men their
eternity may be pretty crummy
but so long as they go out on a limb
their friendship will never again
be half-baked ready for more
head-scratching awe-inspiring
mind-numbing make you look like a genius
to all your friends brain teasers
try your hand at one of these classic
challenges and show
everyone just how smart you really are
[Music]